Yeardley: So USB C hub for MacBook Air.
Thank you, Apple, for eliminating
all ports of all kinds
so that we have to buy dongles.
I'm Yeardley Smith.
You may know me best as
the voice of Lisa Simpson.
I bought some Adidas Alphabounce shoes.
I'm actually not a sneakerhead.
I kind of, I work out.
I work out hard, and I
have one pair of sneakers.
These are zero-drop. That's a thing.
I get plantar fasciitis.
These seem to work out for me.
These happen to be, what was that color?
They're like blush or almond or something.
I also got this SkinMedica
Rejuvenating Hydrator.
This was a recommendation that
was given to me when I was
shopping at Sephora one
day when I was out of town
shooting a movie for my production company
in Hammond, Louisiana,
a couple of months ago.
And I really liked it.
It's kinda spendy, and I'm not that girl.
Like, I don't really get
spendy skin products,
but I quite like this,
so I use it at night,
and I use it under my foundation.
Does it work?
I don't know, but it doesn't
not work, so there's that.
Turmeric curcumin 'cause
my general practitioner
told me that cultures
that put a lot of turmeric
in their food don't lose their minds.
They don't get dementia. I'm
all about that. Sign me up.
And I like curry, so
I'll put it in my food.
I'll take it in a capsule.
I'll just keep taking it.
I'll just, you know, sign me up.
Load me in. I'm good.
And it turns your poo yellow, OK.
So I bought 10 Oral-B
replacement toothbrush heads
for my electric toothbrush
because I actually
have a slight obsession with oral hygiene.
I floss all the time.
When I go out, like when
I'm on the red carpet,
here's a little secret about
me, I actually have a little
mini dental floss in my evening bag.
I floss all the time, and I
brush my teeth like crazy.
So I change my toothbrush once
a month. I'm kind of a nut.
So, yeah, I needed 10 of those.
So USB C hub for MacBook Air.
Thank you, Apple, for eliminating
all ports of all kinds
so that we have to buy dongles
and all kinds of extra
things for everything.
At the same time, I really
love my MacBook Air.
I know, I get it, you have
me over a barrel, fine.
The Expo Dry Erase Marker in red
because I have a gym in my house and we,
my trainer writes the
unbearable workout on the mirror
in red dry-erase marker.
Jerk.
Electrolyte concentrate.
News flash: This one, it's unsweetened.
It tastes, if you put too
much in, it's kind of sour.
Nothing is better for a hangover,
if that ever happens to you.
Never happens to me.
Or if you find yourself
just generally dehydrated,
just add it to your water,
and it's better than Gatorade
'cause it has no sugar or additives.
Organic barley-grass powder.
Again, my trainer said,
"Yeardley, you need this.
It will cure what ails you."
I'm not even sure what
that is, what ails me.
But I'm like, "OK, sign me up."
So I put it in my smoothie,
which I call the Black Beauty.
So basically it's water,
it's wild blueberries,
a little bit of ice,
this barley-grass powder,
some spirulina, and that's it.
Producer: Sounds delish.
Yeardley: It's delish, and it's black.
I'm not even kidding.
It's, yeah, it's for real.
Here we are again with my
obsession with oral hygiene.
Eight Pronamel tubes of toothpaste.
I do have sensitive teeth,
probably 'cause I brush them so much,
and I do like the fresh-breath
flavor. This is good.
And again with the dental
floss, so there you go.
And I like the Glide because
it slides right between the teeth.
You know, it's really
easy, and it's sorta tasty.
Stars are just like us.
Oh, you do want to brush your
teeth twice a day because
that will catch up with you in
hot minute when you're older.
It will be so much worse, so much worse.